Yes, OK, four, three,
two, one, OK, I
see you guys are
in a happy mood.
I don't know if that
means 18.06 is ending,
or, the quiz was good.
Uh, my birthday
conference was going
on at the time of the quiz, and
in the conference, of course,
everybody had to
say nice things,
but I was wondering,
what would my 18.06
class be saying, because it was
at the exactly the same time.
But, what I know from
the grades so far,
they're basically close to, and
maybe slightly above the grades
that you got on quiz two.
So, very satisfactory.
And, then we have a
final exam coming up,
and today's lecture,
as I told you by email,
will be a first
step in the review,
and then on Wednesday
I'll do all I can
in reviewing the whole course.
So my topic today
is -- actually,
this is a lecture I have never
given before in this way,
and it will -- well,
four subspaces,
that's certainly fundamental,
and you know that,
so I want to speak
about left-inverses
and right-inverses and
then something called
pseudo-inverses.
And pseudo-inverses,
let me say right away,
that comes in near the
end of chapter seven,
and that would not be
expected on the final.
But you'll see that
what I'm talking about
is really the basic stuff that,
for an m-by-n matrix of rank r,
we're going back to the most
fundamental picture in linear
algebra.
Nobody could forget
that picture, right?
When you're my age, even,
you'll remember the row space,
and the null space.
Orthogonal complements over
there, the column space
and the null space of
A transpose column,
orthogonal
complements over here.
And I want to speak
about inverses.
OK.
And I want to identify the
different possibilities.
So first of all,
when does a matrix
have a just a perfect
inverse, two-sided, you know,
so the two-sided inverse is what
we just call inverse, right?
And, so that means that
there's a matrix that
produces the identity, whether
we write it on the left
or on the right.
And just tell me, how
are the numbers r,
the rank, n the number of
columns, m the number of rows,
how are those
numbers related when
we have an invertible matrix?
So this is the
matrix which was --
chapter two was all
about matrices like this,
the beginning of the course,
what was the relation of th-
of r, m, and n,
for the nice case?
They're all the same, all equal.
So this is the case when r=m=n.
Square matrix, full
rank, period, just --
so I'll use the words full rank.
OK, good.
Everybody knows that.
OK.
Then chapter three.
We began to deal with matrices
that were not of full rank,
and they could have any rank,
and we learned what the rank
was.
And then we focused,
if you remember
on some cases like
full column rank.
Now, can you remember what was
the deal with full column rank?
So, now, I think this
is the case in which we
have a left-inverse,
and I'll try to find it.
So we have a --
what was the situation there?
It's the case of full column
rank, and that means --
what does that mean about r?
It equals, what's
the deal with r, now,
if we have full
column rank, I mean
the columns are independent,
but maybe not the rows.
So what is r equal
to in this case?
n.
Thanks.
r=n.
The n columns are
independent, but probably, we
have more rows.
What's the picture, and then
what's the null space for this?
So the n columns
are independent,
what's the null
space in this case?
So of course, you
know what I'm asking.
You're saying, why is this guy
asking something, I know that--
I think about it in my sleep,
right?
So the null space of this
matrix if the rank is
n, the null space is what
vectors are in the null space?
Just the zero vector.
Right?
The columns are independent.
Independent columns.
No combination of the columns
gives zero except that one.
And what's my picture over, --
let me redraw my picture --
the row space is everything.
No.
Is that right?
Let's see, I often get
these turned around, right?
So what's the deal?
The columns are
independent, right?
So the rank should be the full
number of columns, so what
does that tell us?
There's no null space, right.
OK.
The row space is
the whole thing.
Yes, I won't even
draw the picture.
And what was the deal with --
and these were very important
in least squares problems
because --
So, what more is true here?
If we have full column rank,
the null space is zero,
we have independent
columns, the unique --
so we have zero or
one solutions to Ax=b.
There may not be any solutions,
but if there's a solution,
there's only one solution
because other solutions are
found by adding on stuff
from the null space,
and there's nobody
there to add on.
So the particular
solution is the solution,
if there is a
particular solution.
But of course, the
rows might not be -
are probably not independent
-- and therefore,
so right-hand sides won't end
up with a zero equal zero after
elimination, so sometimes
we may have no solution,
or one solution.
OK.
And what I want to say is
that for this matrix A --
oh, yes, tell me something about
A transpose A in this case.
So this whole part of the board,
now, is devoted to this case.
What's the deal
with A transpose A?
I've emphasized over and over
how important that combination
is, for a rectangular
matrix, A transpose A
is the good thing to look
at, and if the rank is n,
if the null space
has only zero in it,
then the same is true
of A transpose A.
That's the beautiful fact, that
if the rank of A is n, well,
we know this will be an
n by n symmetric matrix,
and it will be full rank.
So this is invertible.
This matrix is invertible.
That matrix is invertible.
And now I want to show
you that A itself has
a one-sided inverse.
Here it is.
The inverse of that, which
exists, times A transpose,
there is a one-sided --
shall I call it A inverse?
-- left of the matrix A.
Why do I say that?
Because if I multiply this
guy by A, what do I get?
What does that
multiplication give?
Of course, you
know it instantly,
because I just put
the parentheses there,
I have A transpose A
inverse times A transpose A
so, of course,
it's the identity.
So it's a left inverse.
And this was the totally
crucial case for least squares,
because you remember that least
squares, the central equation
of least squares had this
matrix, A transpose A,
as its coefficient matrix.
And in the case of
full column rank,
that matrix is
invertible, and we're go.
So that's the case where
there is a left-inverse.
So A does whatever it does,
we can find a matrix that
brings it back to the identity.
Now, is it true that,
in the other order --
so A inverse left times
A is the identity.
Right?
This matrix is m by n.
This matrix is n by m.
The identity matrix is n by n.
All good.
All good if you're n.
But if you try to put that
matrix on the other side,
it would fail.
If the full column rank --
if this is smaller than m,
the case where they're
equals is the beautiful case,
but that's all set.
Now, we're looking
at the case where
the columns are independent
but the rows are not.
So this is invertible,
but what matrix is not
invertible?
A A transpose is
bad for this case.
A transpose A is good.
So we can multiply on the
left, everything good,
we get the left inverse.
But it would not be
a two-sided inverse.
A rectangular matrix can't
have a two-sided inverse,
because there's got to be
some null space, right?
If I have a matrix
that's rectangular,
then either that
matrix or its transpose
has some null space, because
if n and m are different,
then there's going to be
some free variables around,
and we'll have some null
space in that direction.
OK, tell me the corresponding
picture for the opposite case.
So now I'm going to ask
you about right-inverses.
A right-inverse.
And you can fill
this all out, this
is going to be the
case of full row rank.
And then r is equal to m, now,
the m rows are independent,
but the columns are not.
So what's the deal on that?
Well, just exactly
the flip of this one.
The null space of A
transpose contains only zero,
because there are no
combinations of the rows that
give the zero row.
We have independent rows.
And in a minute, I'll give
an example of all these.
So, how many solutions
to Ax=b in this case?
The rows are independent.
So we can always solve Ax=b.
Whenever elimination
never produces a zero row,
so we never get into that
zero equal one problem,
so Ax=b always has a
solution, but too many.
So there will be some null
space, the null space of A --
what will be the dimension
of A's null space?
How many free
variables have we got?
How many special solutions in
that null space have we got?
So how many free
variables in this setup?
We've got n columns,
so n variables,
and this tells us
how many are pivot
variables, that tells us
how many pivots there are,
so there are n-m free variables.
So there are infinitely
many solutions to Ax=b.
We have n-m free
variables in this case.
OK.
Now I wanted to ask about
this idea of a right-inverse.
OK.
So I'm going to have a matrix
A, my matrix A, and now
there's going to be some
inverse on the right that
will give the identity matrix.
So it will be A times A inverse
on the right, will be I.
And can you tell me
what, just by comparing
with what we had up there,
what will be the right-inverse,
we even have a formula for it.
There will be other --
actually, there are
other left-inverses,
that's our favorite.
There will be other
right-inverses,
but tell me our favorite here,
what's the nice right-inverse?
The nice right-inverse
will be, well, there we
had A transpose A
was good, now it
will be A A transpose
that's good.
The good matrix,
the good right --
the thing we can invert
is A A transpose,
so now if I just do it that way,
there sits the right-inverse.
You see how completely parallel
it is to the one above?
Right.
So that's the right-inverse.
So that's the case
when there is --
In terms of this
picture, tell me
what the null spaces are like
so far for these three cases.
What about case
one, where we had
a two-sided inverse, full
rank, everything great.
The null spaces were,
like, gone, right?
The null spaces were
just the zero vectors.
Then I took case two,
this null space was gone.
Case three, this null space was
gone, and then case four is,
like, the most general case when
this picture is all there --
when all the null spaces --
this has dimension r, of course,
this has dimension n-r,
this has dimension r,
this has dimension m-r, and the
final case will be when r is
smaller than m and n.
But can I just,
before I leave here
look a little more at this one?
At this case of
full column rank?
So A inverse on the left,
it has this left-inverse
to give the identity.
I said if we multiply
it in the other order,
we wouldn't get the identity.
But then I just realized that I
should ask you, what do we get?
So if I put them in
the other order --
if I continue this down below,
but I write A times A inverse
left -- so there's A
times the left-inverse,
but it's not on
the left any more.
So it's not going to
come out perfectly.
But everybody in this room
ought to recognize that matrix,
right?
Let's see, is that
the guy we know?
Am I OK, here?
What is that matrix?
P. Thanks.
P. That matrix --
it's a projection.
It's the projection
onto the column space.
It's trying to be the
identity matrix, right?
A projection matrix tries
to be the identity matrix,
but you've given it,
an impossible job.
So it's the identity
matrix where it can be,
and elsewhere, it's
the zero matrix.
So this is P, right.
A projection onto
the column space.
And if I asked you this one,
and put these in the opposite
OK. order -- so this
came from up here.
And similarly, if I try to put
the right inverse on the left
--
so that, like, came from above.
This, coming from
this side, what
happens if I try to put the
right inverse on the left?
Then I would have A transpose
A, A transpose inverse A,
if this matrix is
now on the left, what
do you figure that matrix is?
It's going to be a
projection, too, right?
It looks very much
like this guy,
except the only difference
is, A and A transpose
have been reversed.
So this is a projection,
this is another projection,
onto the row space.
Again, it's trying
to be the identity,
but there's only so
much the matrix can do.
And this is the projection
onto the column space.
So let me now go back
to the main picture
and tell you about the general
case, the pseudo-inverse.
These are cases we know.
So this was important review.
You've got to know the
business about these ranks,
and the free variables --
really, this is linear
algebra coming together.
And, you know, one nice
thing about teaching 18.06,
It's not trivial.
But it's --
I don't know, somehow, it's
nice when it comes out right.
I mean -- well, I shouldn't say
anything bad about calculus,
but I will.
I mean, like, you
know, you have formulas
for surface area, and other
awful things and, you know,
they do their best in
calculus, but it's not elegant.
And, linear algebra just
is -- well, you know,
linear algebra is about
the nice part of calculus,
where everything's, like, flat,
and, the formulas come out
right.
And you can go into
high dimensions
where, in calculus,
you're trying
to visualize these things,
well, two or three dimensions
is kind of the limit.
But here, we don't --
you know, I've stopped
doing two-by-twos,
I'm just talking about
the general case.
OK, now I really will speak
about the general case here.
What could be the inverse --
what's a kind of
reasonable inverse
for a matrix for the
completely general matrix where
there's a rank r, but
it's smaller than n,
so there's some null space
left, and it's smaller
than m, so a transpose
has some null space,
and it's those null spaces
that are screwing up inverses,
right?
Because if a matrix
takes a vector to zero,
well, there's no way an inverse
can, like, bring it back
to life.
My topic is now
the pseudo-inverse,
and let's just by a
picture, see what's
the best inverse we could have?
So, here's a vector
x in the row space.
I multiply by A.
Now, the one thing everybody
knows is you take a vector,
you multiply by A,
and you get an output,
and where is that output?
Where is Ax?
Always in the
column space, right?
Ax is a combination
of the columns.
So Ax is somewhere here.
So I could take all the
vectors in the row space.
I could multiply them all by A.
I would get a bunch of
vectors in the column space
and what I think is, I'd get all
the vectors in the column space
just right.
I think that this
connection between an x
in the row space and an Ax
in the column space, this
is one-to-one.
We got a chance, because
they have the same
dimension.
That's an r-dimensional
space, and that's
an r-dimensional space.
And somehow, the matrix A --
it's got these null
spaces hanging around,
where it's knocking vectors to
And then it's got all the
vectors in between, zero.
which is almost all vectors.
Almost all vectors have
a row space component
and a null space
component.
And it's killing the
null space component.
But if I look at the vectors
that are in the row space,
with no null space component,
just in the row space,
then they all go into
the column space,
so if I put another vector,
let's say, y, in the row space,
I positive that wherever
Ay is, it won't hit Ax.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Let's see why.
All right.
So here's what I said.
If x and y are in the
row space, then A x
is not the same as A y.
They're both in the
column space, of course,
but they're different.
That would be a perfect
question on a final exam,
because that's what
I'm teaching you
in that material
of chapter three
and chapter four,
especially chapter three.
If x and y are in the row space,
then Ax is different from Ay.
So what this means --
and we'll see why --
is that, in words, from the
row space to the column space,
A is perfect, it's
an invertible matrix.
If we, like, limited
it to those spaces.
And then, its
inverse will be what
I'll call the pseudo-inverse.
So that's that the
pseudo-inverse is.
It's the inverse -- so A goes
this way, from x to y -- sorry,
x to A x, from y to A y,
that's A, going that way.
Then in the other direction,
anything in the column space
comes from somebody
in the row space,
and the reverse there is what
I'll call the pseudo-inverse,
and the accepted
notation is A plus.
So y will be A plus x.
I'm sorry.
No, y will be A plus times
whatever it started with, A y.
Do you see my picture there?
Same, of course, for x and A x.
This way, A does it, the other
way is the pseudo-inverse,
and the pseudo-inverse
just kills this stuff,
and the matrix just kills this
stuff.
So everything that's really
serious here is going
on in the row space and
the column space, and now,
tell me --
this is the fundamental
fact, that between those two
r-dimensional spaces,
our matrix is perfect.
Why?
Suppose they weren't.
Why do I get into trouble?
Suppose -- so, proof.
I haven't written
down proof very much,
but I'm going to
use that word once.
Suppose they were the same.
Suppose these are supposed
to be two different vectors.
Maybe I'd better make
the statement correctly.
If x and y are different
vectors in the row space --
maybe I'll better put if
x is different from y,
both in the row space --
so I'm starting with two
different vectors in the row
space, I'm multiplying by A --
so these guys are in the column
space, everybody knows
that, and the point is,
they're different over there.
So, suppose they weren't.
Suppose A x=A y.
Suppose, well, that's the
same as saying A(x-y) is zero.
So what?
So, what do I know
now about (x-y),
what do I know
about this vector?
Well, I can see right
away, what space is it in?
It's sitting in the
null space, right?
So it's in the null space.
But what else do
I know about it?
Here it was x in the row
space, y in the row space,
what about x-y?
It's also in the
row space, right?
Heck, that thing
is a vector space,
and if the vector space
is anything at all,
if x is in the row space,
and y is in the row space,
then the difference is also,
so it's also in the row space.
So what?
Now I've got a vector x-y
that's in the null space,
and that's also in the row
space, so what vector is it?
It's the zero vector.
So I would conclude
from that that x-y
had to be the zero vector,
x-y, so, in other words,
if I start from two
different vectors,
I get two different vectors.
If these vectors are the
same, then those vectors
had to be the same.
That's like the algebra proof,
which we understand completely
because we really understand
these subspaces of what
I said in words, that
a matrix A is really
a nice, invertible mapping
from row space to columns pace.
If the null spaces
keep out of the way,
then we have an inverse.
And that inverse is
called the pseudo inverse,
and it's a very, very,
useful in application.
Statisticians
discovered, oh boy, this
is the thing that we
needed all our lives,
and here it finally showed
up, the pseudo-inverse
is the right thing.
Why do statisticians need it?
And because statisticians
are like least-squares-happy.
I mean they're always
doing least squares.
And so this is their
central linear regression.
Statisticians who may
watch this on video,
please forgive that
description of your interests.
One of your interests is linear
regression and this problem.
But this problem is only OK
provided we have full column
rank.
And statisticians have to worry
all the time about, oh, God,
maybe we just repeated
an experiment.
You know, you're taking
all these measurements,
maybe you just repeat
them a few times.
You know, maybe they're
not independent.
Well, in that case, that
A transpose A matrix
that they depend on
becomes singular.
So then that's when they
needed the pseudo-inverse,
it just arrived at
the right moment,
and it's the right quantity.
OK.
So now that you know what the
pseudo-inverse should do, let
me see what it is.
Can we find it?
So this is my -- to
complete the lecture is --
how do I find this
pseudo-inverse A plus?
OK.
Well, here's one way.
Everything I do today is
to try to review stuff.
One way would be to
start from the SVD.
The Singular Value
Decomposition.
And you remember
that that factored A
into an orthogonal matrix
times this diagonal matrix
times this orthogonal matrix.
But what did that
diagonal guy look like?
This diagonal guy, sigma,
has some non-zeroes,
and you remember, they
came from A transpose A,
and A A transpose, these
are the good guys, and then
some more zeroes, and all zeroes
there, and all zeroes there.
So you can guess what
the pseudo-inverse is,
I just invert stuff that's
nice to invert -- well,
what's the
pseudo-inverse of this?
That's what the
problem comes down to.
What's the pseudo-inverse of
this beautiful diagonal matrix?
But it's got a
null space, right?
What's the rank of this matrix?
What's the rank of
this diagonal matrix?
r, of course.
It's got r non-zeroes,
and then it's otherwise,
zip.
So it's got n columns, it's got
m rows, and it's got rank r.
It's the best example, the
simplest example we could ever
have of our general setup.
OK?
So what's the pseudo-inverse?
What's the matrix --
so I'll erase our columns,
because right below it,
I want to write
the pseudo-inverse.
OK, you can make a
pretty darn good guess.
If it was a proper diagonal
matrix, invertible,
if there weren't any zeroes
down here, if it was sigma one
to sigma n, then everybody
knows what the inverse would be,
the inverse would be one over
sigma one, down to one over s-
but of course, I'll
have to stop at sigma r.
And, it will be the rest,
zeroes again, of course.
And now this one was
m by n, and this one
is meant to have a slightly
different, you know,
transpose shape, n by m.
They both have that rank r.
My idea is that the
pseudo-inverse is the best --
is the closest I can
come to an inverse.
So what is sigma times
its pseudo-inverse?
Can you multiply sigma
by its pseudo-inverse?
Multiply that by that?
What matrix do you get?
They're diagonal.
Rectangular, of course.
But of course, we're
going to get ones, R ones,
and all the rest, zeroes.
And the shape of that, this
whole matrix will be m by
m.
And suppose I did it
in the other order.
Suppose I did sigma plus sigma.
Why don't I do it
right underneath?
in the opposite order?
See, this matrix hasn't
got a left-inverse,
it hasn't got a right-inverse,
but every matrix
has got a pseudo-inverse.
If I do it in the order sigma
plus sigma, what do I get?
Square matrix, this is
m by n, this is m by m,
my result is going to m by
m -- is going to be n by n,
and what is it?
Those are diagonal
matrices, it's
going to be ones,
and then zeroes.
It's not the same as that,
it's a different size --
it's a projection.
One is a projection matrix
onto the column space,
and this one is the projection
matrix onto the row space.
That's the best that
pseudo-inverse can do.
So what the
pseudo-inverse does is,
if you multiply on the left,
you don't get the identity,
if you multiply
on the right, you
don't get the identity, what
you get is the projection.
It brings you into the two
good spaces, the row space
and column space.
And it just wipes
out the null space.
So that's what the
pseudo-inverse of this diagonal
one is, and then the
pseudo-inverse of A itself --
this is perfectly invertible.
What's the inverse
of V transpose?
Just another tiny bit of review.
That's an orthogonal matrix,
and its inverse is V, good.
This guy has got all
the trouble in it,
all the null space
is responsible for,
so it doesn't have
a true inverse,
it has a pseudo-inverse,
and then the inverse of U
is U transpose, thanks.
Or, of course, I
could write U inverse.
So, that's the question of, how
do you find the pseudo-inverse
--
so what statisticians do
when they're in this --
so this is like the case of
where least squares breaks down
because the rank is --
you don't have full rank,
and the beauty of the singular
value decomposition is,
it puts all the problems into
this diagonal matrix where
it's clear what to do.
It's the best inverse you
could think of is clear.
You see there could be other --
I mean, we could put
some stuff down here,
it would multiply these zeroes.
It wouldn't have any effect,
but then the good pseudo-inverse
is the one with no extra
stuff, it's sort of, like,
as small as possible.
It has to have those
to produce the ones.
If it had other stuff, it
would just be a larger matrix,
so this pseudo-inverse is kind
of the minimal matrix that
gives the best result.
Sigma sigma plus being r ones.
SK.
so I guess I'm hoping --
pseudo-inverse, again,
let me repeat what
I said at the very beginning.
This pseudo-inverse,
which appears
at the end, which is in
section seven point four,
and probably I did more with
it here than I did in the book.
The word pseudo-inverse will
not appear on an exam in this
course, but I think if you
see this all will appear,
because this is all what the
course was about, chapters one,
two, three, four --
but if you see all that,
then you probably see,
well, OK, the general case
had both null spaces around,
and this is the
natural thing to do.
So, this is one way to
find the pseudo-inverse.
Yes.
The point of a pseudo-inverse,
of computing a pseudo-inverse
is to get some factors
where you can find
the pseudo-inverse quickly.
And this is, like, the
champion, because this
is where we can invert
those, and those two, easily,
just by transposing, and we
know what to do with a diagonal.
OK, that's as much
review, maybe --
let's have a five-minute holiday
in 18.06 and, I'll see you
Wednesday, then,
for the rest of this
course.
Thanks.